hey you know you feel like some company
i want to facetime some friends what do
you think oh yeah let's talk about
something
all right uh no oh look at these two
guys listen
two of the smartest
most respected voices i know these two
gentlemen dave zirin and natan thomas
co-host of the collision these two cats
been on the front lines
of the intersection of sports and
politics before it was trendy so we were
going to look back at week one
and not just week one but also we'll
talk about naomi osaka
we're gonna look at athlete activism
right now who better to talk to the
desire that's right sports editor at the
nation and four maybe a player tom
thomas noted author and motivational
speaker fellas thank you all for coming
in uh itada i'll start with you man
listen uh just what was your take away
from the demonstrations across the
league uh yesterday throughout the nfl
oh goodness i mean it was really the
response i mean going back to you know
you know kansas kansas city and the
booze that happened after that and it
was so crazy because you know it was
right before
september 11th and it could have been
this moment where you had like a
storybook you know what i mean like it
like the black players the white players
you know standing together in unity to
you know fight for equality all of that
stuff and you know the kansas city fans
just ruined it they just booed and i was
like wait they're booing equality like
what they're not even this had nothing
to do with the national anthem this time
because they're not nailing during the
national anthem this all took place
after it so it that that was
disheartening to really see and i saw
the mayor was like you know
a few people in kansas city did this but
not all of us you know i'm like ah that
might be wishful thinking and booze
sounded kind of loud so i think it just
ruined what could have been a very
special moment
and i'll i'll ask you both uh etan and
dave why do you think they booed let's
just get right to it why did they boo in
your opinion
all right well there's so much to say
why did they boo i mean they booed
because the league has conditioned the
fans for the last four years
to actually disagree with the idea of
players using their platform to speak
out for racial justice let alone speak
out against police brutality like i put
this on the nfl as much as i put it on
the fans it's the nfl
that has exiled colin kaepernick it's
the nfl that has sent the message to the
players themselves about what they can
or cannot do it's the nfl that now is
trying to switch their tune because
they're dancing as fast as they can
roger goodell is doing a soft shoe like
sammy davis jr because he's so terrified
at the thought of nfl players going on
strike like their nba and major league
baseball brethren and and seeing uh the
billions of dollars go down the tubes if
that takes place and so that gets to the
original question michael about what i
thought of yesterday i thought it was
like this very interesting battle and
fight between what the nfl was trying to
put forward and then players themselves
trying to fight through that fog
fight through that branding for black
lives matter and trying to have a
message actually heard about police
brutality and police violence so you
have that amazing scene out in atlanta
which i think we should got to talk more
about i thought it was one of the most
amazing things i've ever seen of seattle
kicking off and then letting just the
ball fall to the turf and then both
teams take a knee um i spoke to somebody
who was talking to the seattle players
about this plan that was totally worked
out without management that was the
players talking to each other and that's
the kind of demonstrations that gives me
a sense of confidence
yeah if it was player-led absolutely
because that's much less permissive and
much it feels much less co-opted what
you're talking about it feels much less
coordinated uh you know and just it just
frankly kind of watered down at times
that's what kind of frustrates me about
the whole thing
is you know we've come
the pendulum has swung to the opposite
extreme which feels like it almost
undermines
the power and the provocation of the
protests because it's so packaged and
prepared and use the word branding just
now dave it's just you know everybody's
kind of you know across the league
trying so hard to to strike a balance of
neutrality you know what i mean they're
trying to they're trying to have
something that's not controversial that
doesn't offend utahn and it feels like
that completely takes away from the
meaning of a protest
well i mean i have to respectfully
disagree especially when it comes to the
nba you know me and dave are going back
and forth on this topic a lot you know
the adam silver is a lot different than
david stern so under david stern you
know you know everybody has to remember
that craig hodges in my mood
got white ball under david stern adam
silver is a little bit different so when
you're working with players to be able
to value their voices and and it's a
totally different relationship so it
doesn't have to be as much adversarial
if it was david stern oh then it would
be completely the players against them
against management so it would be a
completely different uh situation as a
whole
well just well just to clarify something
i'm strictly talking about the nfl in
that case in this in this case because
there's at least adam silver in that
league that's we know that's a black
league in a players league there's some
credibility there from an mba standpoint
more so at least compared to the nfl is
what i mean i'm strictly talking about
the juxtaposition of an nfl that's
that's black ball kaepernick and reid
having n racism in its end zone dave's
iron yeah if you had played a drinking
game yesterday and taken a shot every
single time that the announcers actually
used the word police
you would have been stone sober by the
end of three hours six hours or nine
hours i mean there was such an effort to
phrase it in terms of this is about
unity this is about racial uplift this
is about uh the league coming together
to say can we do more and it's like do
more about what uplift against what what
are you talking about right when and not
saying that no it's like what is this
really being informed by when you say
things like enough or how many more
finish that sentence it's how many more
people have to die at the hands of
police enough with unarmed people of
color being killed by police it's like
they don't want to say that part because
that's when it gets really polarizing
and that's when it goes from a
celebration of unity to an actual demand
you you referenced uh mike kaepernick's
tweet about blackballing kaepernick and
reed out of the league right
why read though i mean reid played last
year
and if they are if they are trying to
keep them out of league it's a little
late why are they trying to keep league
reed out of the league right now if you
agree with that position from kaepernick
dave and then uh etan from you're here
here's the tweet right now
well i think it's just that that reed is
sitting there at 28 years old uh he set
franchise records last year for the
carolina panthers and it just it leaves
this question that's just hanging there
about why doesn't eric reid have work at
this point i mean given what we saw
yesterday in this past happy league i
mean my goodness when gardner minshew
was completing 95 of his passes you
might need some decent safety work out
there in the nfl and here's eric reid's
just just sitting there and so it's just
i think it raises that question again
and again about who is allowed and who
isn't allowed in the league because i'm
still convinced like when it comes to
ownership in the nfl they like having
these players out of the league so they
can use them as kind of ghost stories to
tell the younger players about you need
to stay in line and listen so i do think
we're also seeing now a gap between the
nfl offices roger goodell his team over
there and what they're trying to do and
then these 32 were really 31 because of
green bay but 31 very conservative um
over white except for jacksonville
owners uh who have a different kind of
political agenda
hey tom oh yeah i definitely agree with
everything dave just said i mean you
know eric reid it's it's interesting
because it takes me back to seeing jay-z
and roger goodell you know at the press
conference while kaepernick is still
white bald from the league you know i
mean are they talking about they want to
move forward they want to do this and
they want to do that but meanwhile
catherine's
lead
and so it's it's it's interesting
because you know eric reid has been he
was right there kneeling with kaepernick
the entire time and even though that he
was in the league last year they made it
pretty tough for him you know i mean
there's a reason why he was talking
about why am i getting drug tested all
these times like why am i you know and
it was almost as if they wanted him to
be out of the league to say okay he's
one of the bad ones all right we're
gonna put him over there with kaepernick
but you all you know we're going to be
able to work with you and you have to
have somebody that says that clay will
that's not all right
you know what i want to welcome
oh i'm sorry
let me just ask one more i have an mba
question i want to ask before we uh
before we step off here you know george
hill was very outspoken with the
milwaukee bucks he said hey look we
should have never come to this damn
bubble this is this is right after the
james blake uh shooting in kenosha and
other players were saying hey it didn't
work
our messaging you know black lives
matter we're saying all this stuff it
didn't work
uh one do you agree with that do you
agree that they never should have come
to the bubble and they should have
stayed outside to
outside of that bubble to to get their
message across and is is it working or
was it working uh in your opinion
i think that there's
i think there's the case to be made for
both of them to be honest with you in
all honesty i think there's a case he
made for both and it's just interesting
seeing people like you know i don't
sometimes i don't like calling out
specific names but seeing people like
stephen a smith we'll just say st ray
smith for a minute you know we can say
him now we you know we're not on espn or
anything like that we just it's nice
to say anything we can say anything here
eton anything go ahead
but but you see where all the players
when they when they when they decided to
to um
to protest so they started they signed
to boycott and everything like that for
for the few games right two games you
saw all the people all of a suddenly say
oh we praise these players it's great
what they're doing how much respect they
have but then just a little bit while
before they lambasted people like kyrie
irving like dwight howard like every
bradley when he was suggesting that
players not go into the bubble for that
very reason that you just just just said
and i think it's interesting because
there are different ways to be able to
approach this i mean you saw back in the
68 olympics you saw john carlos and
tommy smith they went to the olympics
and they had a they had a um a
demonstration they had a moment that is
solidified in time even to today but
then you had somebody like criminal duja
bar who elected not to go and so both of
them the respects i just don't like why
at that time there was such this divide
of saying okay the players that want to
go you know they're doing things the
right way the players that don't want to
go they're complete buffoons and they're
fools and they have no idea what they're
talking about and why just stephen
it was charles barkley it was michael
wilbon i got you know it was a lot of
people so now when you're seeing players
say okay this didn't really work the way
that we thought that it that it would
have
worked they they they have a legitimate
argument what i would like to see for
the players to do is to ask for more
they have everybody's attention they had
a board of governors meeting there you
know what i mean and i want to see them
ask for more i want to see them push
these billionaire ceos i don't call them
owners for obvious reasons but i want to
see them push them to be able to use
their power and their influence in this
particular cities where they're in to
push for actual change the way that we
just saw fedex push for the end of the
washington football team to change the
name and they said if you don't you're
going to lose us as sponsors you know
what i mean that's what makes people
change not because dan snyder just woke
up and said you know what
i'm tired of offending these native
american people i think i'm going to
start messing with their
money yeah
but
everything changes but these
billionaires
they have the power to go into the
cities where they are and pressure the
city to do that same thing with police
departments i want the players to ask
for more like don't just be satisfied
with you know them saying black lives
matter in the camera or anything like
that i want more from them
all right ichan and dave you guys can
come back here and hang out anytime with
us we appreciate you coming on there's
much more with this conversation so uh
hey thank you thank you for joining us
in our first show on our first show
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports